[Music]
kevin starts off this hour in saginaw
michigan hey kevin how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
awesome i just have a quick question me
and my wife are moving into baby steps
four five and six paid off all our bills
um just this past march and
um question about four five and six is
we're both federal employees um i also
have a military pension spent 25 years
in the army
and we both
have five percent going to tsp just to
get that match
and i was wondering
because tsp we've lost about 10 percent
over the last six or eight months um
should we
work on paying off the home early um
instead of going up to fifteen percent
or
or do both
i guess
i'm desperate if we increase our um psp
to 15 that we're just going to keep
losing
that extra 10 that we're going to throw
in
i don't know what you're invested in in
the tsp but the c plan is not down 10 in
the last six months
um so we have
each of us have 60 in the c and
40 and s
and that's down 10 i think you're
exaggerating
now i just looked at our balances
yesterday and it's
pretty much ten percent
okay
do you really think that that's going to
be that way for the next five years
no okay i don't either i mean the
market's down in general but i didn't
i'm shocked to hear that that mix is
down that far in that period of time i
really am but um i won't dispute you
because i haven't looked at it but the
uh um i know the stock market is down in
general and so
uh
but uh that doesn't keep me from telling
people to invest 15 percent of their
income because the that means the shares
are on sale
right and that's everything i've been
reading too um but again before i pulled
the trigger i just kind of wanted to get
some rein reinforcement from yeah i
would do the tsp to the match and then i
would do a couple of roth iras
um and if that doesn't get you to the 15
i'd put a little more in the tsp to get
you there but i would be doing baby step
four at 15 of your income going in
and then you know work on getting the
house paid off beyond that baby steps
four five six right that works
simultaneously which is um what we teach
there
um
again this economy is weird in an
inflationary economy where there's a
labor shortage
we can't get workers in some areas
um and we're seeing you know people's
paychecks um
going up oh wages are up with wages way
up everybody's saying wages aren't
keeping up with inflation well yeah some
aren't but most are and many times in
many cases wages are causing the
inflation
because every loaf of bread you buy
had to be uh
you know put on a shelf by someone
that's now making twenty dollars an hour
used to make ten dollars an hour
and uh guess what that's built into that
cost loaf of bread so you wonder why the
loaf bread went up that's what it was it
wasn't the magic bread fairy
that did it it was the cost of putting
the bread on the oh and by the way the
gasoline that are diesel fuel that
delivered the bread
because the biden administration's
energy policies have driven gas they're
responsible for that portion of
inflation the rest of it they're getting
blamed for but they're not responsible
for but either way
politics aside arguing about that
doesn't matter
the the bottom line is is that um and
it's very weird in this situation the
stock market's down that's right because
companies a lot of them are making more
than they've ever made
yeah it's just a gloom and doom there's
a black cloud over the market there is
and then there's a lot of headlines out
there you know that tend to make people
freak out you know i saw a couple that
popped up last week uh there might be a
recession and that's gone quiet and i
think what what's important dave i'm
glad you bring up this weird economy is
because we do have some artificial
things that happen as a result of the
pandemic right so you had a lot of
infusion of cash from the federal
government into the marketplace
unemployment uh was up and down now it's
at historic lows wagers that are
all-time high the the the labor market's
going to continue to be hot but probably
for the next couple of years just
because there still is this gap uh for
employment they're looking for companies
are fighting other companies and it's a
grand game of musical chairs if you
remember that elementary school game
but
what i know having worked here for
almost a decade
from uh watching the show before i ever
became a team member here
watching what we teach living what we
teach it is the financial peace
principles the baby steps that allow us
to be in some ways recession proof so
don't freak out about inflation and
recession because what our steps teach i
really believe this is the discipline
and the freedom to be able to pivot when
you need a pivot recessions are real and
so is inflation however when we know
where we're spending the money and we
have some behavior attached to a budget
we don't have to be walking around like
chicken little the sky's falling just
because we see some negative headlines
yeah
yeah
but and here's the other thing that goes
with this and we're not talking really
about kevin's question at that point
um
but back to kevin's question
uh we do not teach
to
and have not lived
uh for decades uh three of them so far
um to uh jump in and out of the stock
market that's right you talk about the
roller coaster
no one gets hurt on a roller coaster
except those that jump off the mill
they're right so
yeah the market is down right now it is
down uh when will it come back up i do
not know that's right i also try not to
predict the weather
um
and uh those that do predict either one
are scary people
uh because they're wrong most the time
and they get to keep their jobs and it's
amazing to me so um
yeah that is a good one but anyway the
uh yeah that's um
the thing you want to do is you want to
have a long-term mindset
with your retirement planning yes you
put money in mutual funds
this month
when it's down
next month when it's up next month when
it's down next month when it's up and
you'll look up and there'll be a million
dollars in there that's right and you'll
be going well how did that happen yeah
and no blood pressure or indigestion if
you're just if you've got a long-term
view which you teach and we've taught
you don't get all hung up in all this
stuff it's ridiculous how much i don't
look at the daily news on it
i just don't even look at it it's not
because i'm scared of it i just don't
care it doesn't change my decision well
at this point you actually being the
model for this whole thing uh it doesn't
actually matter no because i'm not going
to make a decision based on what it did
today well i want to make a decision
what it does over a long period of time
right but not over what it did today
right or what it did in the last three
months and so i'm not that does not
drive my decision making because i
believe in
the value returns on the stock market
over the long haul why do i believe in
that so we've got 70 years with almost a
12 average annual rate of return on the
stock market
look at the s p 500 it's 11.8 percent
for 70 plus years wow
i that's extremely i believe in that you
know and so if it's half of that it
ain't bad
you know but that's the average so far